in this video i explained to you what
cohen's kappa is how it is calculated
and how you can interpret the results
let's start right away with the first
question
what do you need a coin scale before in
general you use the cohen's kappa
whenever you want to assess the
agreement between two raters
in the case of cohen's kappa the
variable to be measured by the two
raters is a nominal variable
therefore if you have a nominal variable
you use the cohen's kappa for your
information if you had an ordinal
variable and two raters you would use
candlesto
and if you had a metric variable you
would use the pearson correlation but
that's enough theory for now let's take
a look at an example
let's say you have developed a measuring
instrument for example a questionnaire
that doctors can use to determine
whether a person is depressed or not
now i give this measuring instrument to
a doctor and have him or her evaluate 50
people with it with your instrument the
first person for example is found to be
depressed the second person is found to
be depressed and the third person is
found not to be depressed
the big question now is does a second
doctor come to the same conclusion
so with the second doctor the result
could now look like this
for the first person
both doctors come to the same results
but for the second person the result
differs
so you're interested now in how big the
agreement of the female and the male
doctor is
if the assessments of the doctors agree
very well
one speaks of a high integrator
reliability
and it is precisely this integrator
reliability
that the cohen's capper measures
so the cohen's kappa is a measure of
integrator reliability
the cohen's capa is therefore a measure
of how reliably two radars measure the
same
so far we have considered the case where
two people measure the same
however the cohen's capper can also be
used when the same rater takes the
measurement at two different times
in that case the cohen's capper
indicates how well the two measurements
of the same person agree
so we can say that the cohen's capper is
a measure of the agreement between two
dependent categorical samples
it is important to note that with
cohen's kappa you can only make a
statement about how reliably both raters
measure the same
but you cannot make a statement about
whether what the two raters measure is
the right thing or not
so if both raters almost always measure
the same thing you would have a very
high cones capper
whether this measured value fits with
the reality
thus the correct is measured cohen's
capper does not tell you in the first
case one speaks of their reliability
and in the second case one speaks of the
validity
now of course the question arises
how is cohen's kappa calculated that is
not difficult for this we create a table
with the frequencies of the respective
answers here we have our two raters each
of them has assessed whether a person is
depressed or not now we want to count
how often both have measured the same
and how often not
so we create a table for ourselves here
we have rater one with not oppressive
and depressive and here we have raider 2
with not depressive and depressive now
we simply keep a tally sheet the first
person rated both people as not
depressed so abash goes in this place
the second person was rated by rater 1
as depressed and by raider 2 as not
depressed
so a dash goes in that space and in the
third case both raters have rated the
person as not depressed we now do this
for all people
let's assume our final result is as
follows
17 people were rated by both raters as
not depressed
for 19 people both raters chose the
rating depressed therefore if both
raters measure the same this person is
on the diagonal if something different
was measured the person is on the edge
here
now we want to know how often both
raters agree and how often they don't
rater 1 and rater 2 agree that 17
patients are not depressed and 19 are
depressed so both raters agree in 36
cases in total 50 people were assessed
with these numbers we can now calculate
the probability that the measurements of
both raters agree in a person we
calculate this by dividing 36 by 50. we
arrive at the following result in 72 of
the cases
both radars assess the same in 28 of the
cases they assess differently this gives
us the first part we need to calculate
cohen's kappa
cohen's kappa is given by this formula
kappa is equal to po minus pe
divided by 1 minus pe
so po which has calculated now what is
pe
if both doctors would answer purely by
chance so to speak simply flipping a
coin whether a person is depressed or
not they would surely come to the same
result in some cases and that is exactly
what pe indicates the hypothetical
probability of a random match but how do
we calculate pe
to calculate pe we first need the sums
in each of the rows and columns
so we have 17 plus 8 which is 25
6 plus 19 which is 25
17 plus 6 which is 23
and 8 plus 19 which is 27 with this we
can now calculate the pe
in the first step we calculate the
probability that both raters would
arrive at the rating not depressed by
chance
raider 1 rated 25 out of 50 people as
not depressed so 50 percent
rate at 2 rated 23 out of 50 people as
not depressed or 46
the overall probability of both radar
saying not depressed by chance is
0.5 times 0.46
which equals 0.23
in the second step we calculate the
probability that the raters would both
say depressed by chance rater 1 says
depressed in 25 out of 50 people or
50 percent
and rater 2 says depressed in 27 out of
50 people or 45
the overall probability of both raiders
saying depressed by chance is
0.5 times 0.54
which equals 0.27
with this we can now calculate pe if
both values are now added we get the
probability that the two raters
coincidentally agree thus pe is given by
0.23
plus
0.27
which is equal to 0.50
therefore if the doctors had no guidance
and simply flipped a coin the
probability of such a match is 50
and for sure there could also be an
other value than 50
now we can calculate cohen's kappa we
simply insert po and pe
and we get a kappa of
0.4 in our example by the way in po the
o stands for observed and in pe the e
stands for expected therefore p o is
what we actually observed and pe is what
we would expect if it were purely random
now we would like to interpret the
results
0.44
stands for moderate reliability
and finally i'll show you how you can
easily calculate cohen's capper for your
data online with data tab
just go to datadeb.net
and copy your own data into this table
now you click on the tab reliability
cohen's cap is calculated for nominal
variables
if your data was found to be metric
please change the scale level under date
of view to nominal
now you just have to click on rater 1
and rater 2 and cohen's capa will be
calculated automatically here above you
can see the cross table
and here below you can read the
calculated cohen's kappa if you don't
know how to interpret the result just
click on the interpretations in words
an integrator reliability analysis was
performed between the dependent samples
of raider 1 and radar 2. for this
purpose the cohen's cap was calculated
which is a measure of the agreement
between two dependent categorical
samples the cohen's capa showed that
there was a weak agreement between
raider 1 and rater 2 with a kappa of
0.23
i hope you enjoyed the video and i will
see you next time